you're a small-town girl like what are
we talking about like when you say small
town do you mean population 850 Wow
yeah I'm from a really small town okay
western southern northeastern
Pennsylvania okay yeah okay and I grew
up doing you know farm chores line
dancing with my mom
you would go line dancing yeah I would
go line dancing every Wednesday with my
mom it was something fun that we would
do together
I don't I've seen it in movies that's
all I know about line dance well funny
enough that movie that I'm here
promoting Philip one of our holding
areas happened to me this like church or
rec center where they were having a real
line dancing evening right and so I got
in there to see if I if I still had it
I don't really know it would be
embarrassing to get into a line to do
line dancing and then immediately start
going the wrong way
yeah but it's the thing where they they
all get in a line and I've just seen
them like they march forward laughs yeah
that's all I you know it's kind of what
it is but if you're going the wrong
direction you just look like an idiot
right is it any of it sexy at all is it
no it's not sexy it's not like twerking
I know a little bit of the tip I didn't
say it was twerking but it was Twitter
hello who said twerk II you know like
you would I don't twerk no Andy's really
into it but you know
it's therapy from my back yeah
cause then there's a part where you
there was a part where you like hit
butts together and stuff like that in
line dancing um there there there's a
dance called the tush push and you do it
a little a little shake oh that's just a
shake it's not there's actually no
contact
what's all very aboveboard yeah way to
show you yes I do
only a few steps okay just yeah show me
what to do I really just wanted to watch
you do it okay I'm a perv but it's heel
tap tap heel heel heel heel okay okay
yeah I've already forgotten yes yeah he
oh yeah I'm like a horse up one two and
then it's that but we don't do it
together we don't waste of my time
he broke an old man's heart
you